oh [__]
good googly moogly ah it's that time you
[__] another fun-filled evening
at the Church of what's happened now if
you're under 18 hang up now [__]
because we're going deep into the murky
waters of death
[Music]
greetings [__] uncle Joey here
Tuesday night waiting on Greg
Fitzsimmons to get this party started
you bad [__] we got the goods
tonight we got the purple ones we got
the red ones we got three containers and
debts and for your viewing pleasure
through this little monster I'm getting
Felisa at plan oh [__] I know she came
from there if you're under 18 hang up
now I don't want the little [__]
killing themselves during my periscope
there you go look at this one here oh
[__] good oh [__] it's that time
[__] Tuesday night the 10th or
the 11th or whatever the [__] it is it
don't matter what day it is uncle Joey's
here never fear you know I'm saying
[Music]
now without further ado it's time for a
little bungalow so don't you agree
enough with the chitty-chat and the
[__] when the [__] whatever the
[__] you know man my back [__] up did
you like Joey what happened to you I got
my shirt on my main man Jay [__] gave
me over there in Pittsburgh I got these
mushrooms from Pittsburgh we're going
deep into the murky waters Lee's already
got spots on his head but it's that type
of night he's I'm saying she came from
Planet Claire she came from Planet
Claire oh yeah she came from Planet
we're ready for Bongo rosolio a little
GDP to put you back in the spirit of
things you follow me and don't never
fear the stars are coming let's break
them on down get this party started
correctly and [__] oh [__] look at this
star one the best edible on the market
for your money [__] 20 bucks gets you
600 milligrams where you gonna get that
action from and I'm not talking about
[__] no sense I'm talking about this
[__] ah
oh yeah we're gonna start off with some
IHOP there's four hey yeah I do
what you got to do you don't say
uncle Joey here never fear you
[__] are having a bad day it's
over
you guys read TMZ today [__] a chicken
sandwich and jalapeno poppers was
Ralphie Mae's last [__] dinner look at
this [__] manga lutea you saying what
you sayin I deal with look at this manga
loop here it's always something now he's
still water on the stars I'm gonna hear
tears about that how he can't eat them
but he don't know we got back up today
[Music]
I'm only a pop them like they gonna stop
why cuz I ain't got time for [__]
around
listen Ike I'm 54 I got one foot in the
grave one a banana peel you understand
me
I gotta do what I gotta do what I got to
do it I don't have much time left so if
I'm gonna sling dick I gotta do it now
you understand
what you're doing so they'll give me a
little mushroom mix it with that edible
just one and down it that's how you do
telling you it's up for the nail so
[__] happy I gave you on me I'm gonna
give me the smallest I'm not gonna give
you this bushy we'll do it together
how's that with the star dead inside
that the flavor don't bother you
[Music]
[__] orange juice
Cara's juices for [__] people who
want diabetes I'm saying just down down
like this see you put it right behind
that's it that's it it's not a weird
texture if you want to give you the
other one the bongo stick here we go
let's do it go get the water ready one
shot
get the water ready get the water ready
get the water in get the water all the
way swallow that [__] there you
go like a savage there you go they know
it's over that's it nobody get the
feeling okay
training [__]
don't be scared uncle Joey's with you
worst case I will put you the trunk of a
car and drop you off on a 170 I got a
spot a pen or 170 a velar stab somebody
or something you got to get rid of
somebody hello I got a spot by the 170
right off a Sherman Way they'll never
find you understand me I can't prove it
I switched my shoes I wear size 9 shoes
you said sign the small details these
[__] oh no about that
I think the Mafia had a way of burying
people in the woods all those years they
buy a pair size 8 shoes you walk around
it for three hours you get a [__]
ingrown toenail well a ingrown toenail
beats going to prison I'm saying why
don't you dance with me God baby that's
it this is to get the water ready right
get the water ready there you go like a
savage there you go there you go like a
soldier don't you go that's it some
people just swallow it don't chew it
okay and she to it it's come even the
stars taste like [__]
okay but if you just want the stars no
you don't like the taste
I didn't chew it I will [__] chew it
let the intestines do the work yeah I'm
saying you eat that lizard meat and they
break it down don't get to that mushroom
within minutes and [__] it's Tuesday
night here on the church [__]
you want to party with the big boys you
want to keep partying with these [__]
fake [__] you know you're not I'm
talking about everybody does everything
but where the Kings are swing [__]
did you say bong it [__] yeah
everybody goes to parties they dance
this mess around
[Music]
it pays to smoke the best anyway Tampa
I'm coming tomorrow night [__]
you better be ready Thursday I want to
hear those stories the [__] tornado
hit you ain't nothing
uncle Joey's coming with a big dick and
a big bag of stars either you're in or
you're out
you understand me the stars are in route
already my friends should be getting
them [__] tomorrow afternoon and by
Thursday all a [__] Tampa Bay will be
jumping up and down clearwater Sarasota
we ain't [__] around [__]
so tell you why you ain't coming home
till [__] mundi cuz uncle Joey's
coming to town I ain't no [__]
stories everybody goes to parties they
dance this mess around you ready for a
little bunion let's give you see let's
start you off with a sativa to say I
treated my sativa to calm him down
what's the difference when you got a mo
more you give the opposite remember the
kid you met at [__] chance Richie
little Richie right Richie was a kid he
was kind of a box we used to give him
speech and that would calm down go sign
up to read a little bit here we go into
the murky waters with my favorite
[__] oh [__] that's the one
that killed doc doula that's the one
that killed Osama bin Laden [__] the
[__] seals that's the one oh when
they put together from the one i jus and
this little kid that drops on wheat once
oh well sometimes you gotta miss the
Jews with the Arabian Sea and see what
you can get you know I'm saying what
tremendous mace who the [__] you can put
it together when it comes to leave mixes
and [__] like that I'm the man I'm
saying
[Music]
that Lobster
anyway what's on your mind beautiful
[__] your uncle Joey's here I'm
queer I'm ready to [__] rock the rest
is up to you you I'm saying you got
[__] what two weeks to Halloween
three weeks to Halloween [__] seven
weeks to Thanksgiving
then another [__] what five weeks
you're running out of time [__]
nobody wants to be broke when Santa
shows up so get your [__] together
tomorrow's another day
bang it out nothing happens on the couch
you dead [__] all you find are
couches pennies and quarters and [__]
peanuts [__] like that
the couch is for [__] Momo's get up
there and remember when doing edibles
you gotta hydrate
cuz if you don't think stuck going out
of control the other night we had a
bunch of [__] I went home I didn't water
when I got home I woke up in the middle
of night dizzy and [__] I was seeing
spots my wife had to get up and give me
water why cuz I didn't take care of
myself
God drink a gallon of water and a baby
[__] ass but before you go to bed so
you won't have a heart attack when you
sleep cuz I was [__] sick I couldn't
get up I was dizzy and [__] did you say
oh my goodness lobster Lobster
[Music]
but the guitarist is dead they're really
good guitars right after the Sacramento
the hair will get you ready for bungle
number two mundo look up seven stars a
stem please push the [__] did you watch
it down ready though yes what is it fun
Wizards mix this is GOP okay
[Music]
that gave me some nice research this
week nice and mild all the way boom
there you go you took the dubonnet's
like a doctor stop buying those paper
pens going to parties thinking that
you're [__] it like the world's most
interesting man you could blow that
smoke up your [__] my dick hole
[__] if you're gonna bawl [__]
smoke thing it's gotta be on that you
want to impress me blow one on a latch
you gonna show up with your little vapor
fence drinking red wine like somebody
sent you
I'll [__] slap your [__] like
that
who sent you I got more rising great
adventure biggy kicking the door waving
the four for all you heard was Papa
don't kick me no more I'm zeroing in on
you [__] I got my eyes on you
what time you got my brother lobster
motion in the ocean who air hose broke
ooh
anyway it's that type of night I know
you had different plans we might have
[__] them up get that bang up put some
ice cubes and that [__] and
let's like this room on fire I'm saying
who do you think started those
California fires [__] you did get
the party started
uncle Joey's here headed to Tampa [__]
Wayne [__] around this weekend this
is hurricane Joey beat showing up with
this [__] [__] Goomba we're
gonna [__] please drop a lot of the
helicopter on Friday morning so get your
[__] together we're just prepping for
Tampa bad couple shroom steps couple
edibles Richter we get down there Friday
[__] your [__] will be passing
out and look like [__] Vietnam by the
time I get rid of [__] that black here
we go lobster
[Music]
lot stuck right you got a CC your
muscles you mind that form uncle Joey
always rock rock
oh [__]
[Music]
oh [__] is the jam right here here's one
of my favorite albums of all time
I wouldn't even listen to this [__]
thing until I seen girls dancing to it
then it was all over in high school here
we go
[Music]
put on their life God pass the tanning
butter but mix this with the [__]
earthquake week in case we got
earthquake we got mushroom soup in
what's a jellyfish
there goes what if I kept things I like
you [__] that's why you guys
without you I'd have dick that's why I
love you [__] thank you for
supporting the church thank you for
supporting the periscope and don't
forget for you [__] degenerate
savages my bookie died AG they'll match
your [__] downpayment 100% get out
you got lakhs this weekend why have a
lot if you're not gonna get paid you put
a bed it with all those [__] people
on the island
you know those [__] people they might
forget you gave us my bookies out AG is
there for you [__] go over there
pressing Church I got a little cash
bonus for you besides that you know I
love you [__] I'm stumped I
feel good you know and that's it and
that's that want to get this thing
started about 10 minutes youtube.com / c
/ Joey Diaz that's the place to be Evan
what else you have to do it you [__]
time nothing you're gonna sit there and
watch my [__] backs Loretta one of
those [__] [__] shows you might as
well hang out with uncle Joey
the [__] and [__] Greg
Fitz I'll see you guys in about 10
minutes don't forget there's just a
couple tickets left for Tampa I don't
want to hear your Friday Joey I need one
ticket for my father he's blind
I don't give a [__] you should have got
the [__] ticket when you should've
got the [__] ticket but you're
[__] around with your friends at
Starbucks
talking about the plans you
you ain't going nowhere you ain't going
nowhere [__] anyway I'll see you
guys in 10 minutes youtube.com slash c /
Joey Diaz if you're in or you're out
or you you simply request that they get
that didn't get my mud tell our ping the
higher